bien le bonsoir
j'aimerais vous faire partager mon
admiration pour ma grande admiration
pour un petit état qui est une très
grande démocratie
alors je sais que dans cette salle quand
on en parle démocratie il ya un certain
nombre de personnes qui grimacent je
dirais quand même que c'est le moins
mauvais des systèmes jeu il suffit
simplement de se référer aux tyrannies
qui sont si nombreuses sur la planète
aujourd'hui tyrannie qui comme vous peut
l'observer dégénère la plupart du temps
en anarchie anarchie ou les peuples
malheureux peuple qui vivent sous ces
régimes vivent un destin qui est
apocalyptique
alors il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
virus qui attaque la démocratie et parmi
les deux plus gros virus qui attaque les
démocraties il ya évidemment la
démagogie il ya la démagogie le
populisme ce sont le premier virus
il ya un autre virus qui est au moins
aussi grave c'est l'impuissance des
citoyens en régime démocratique à
pouvoir s'exprimer mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir que on
parvient quand même les antivirus existe
des anti virus existent pour ce qui est
de la démagogie pour ce qui est du
populisme à écouter c'est simple
l'antivirus appel il faut confronter les
les électeurs il faut confronter les
citoyens aux conséquences de leurs
décisions aux conséquences de leurs
choix politiques
dès l'instant où l'électeur devient tout
d'un coup un citoyen contribuable
généralement il cesse d'être stupide en
tout cas il perd très rapidement des
automatismes de mendicité en dix ans
mais j'ai droit à ça parce
qu'effectivement ça se retrouve sur sa
feuille d'impôts ça c'est un premier
élément ou la citoyenneté est quelque
chose qui amène les gens à devenir très
rapidement adultes il ya un deuxième un
deuxième antivirus contre contre la
démagogie contre tout ça c'est
évidemment de rappeler aux marchands de
cravate que
il nous promettait de raser gratis et
que finalement finalement il n'aura ce
pas gratis et que l'addition nous est
souvent présenté toujours présente et
alors ça c'est là l'aspect démagogie
l'aspect populisme est un autre aspect
c'est l'impuissance effectivement notre
problème à nous en tant que citoyens
c'est d'envoyer quelqu'un dans une
assemblée nous représenter il errait
cependant quatre cinq ans mais il nous
rend finalement très peu de compte de
son activité il n'est que de voir par
exemple les assemblées vide de
représentants tels que nous les montre
parfois les télévisions c'est un
véritable problème c'est un véritable
problème comment peut-on intervenir de
manière régulière pour faire en sorte
que les représentants qui sont supposés
nous représenter que nous avons élus
puissent effectivement nous rendre des
comptes car finalement ce sont d'abord
des commis un ils sont nos représentants
ils sont là pour défendre nos intérêts
bah écoutez là aussi l'antivirus est
connu ça s'appelle la démocratie directe
la démocratie directe vous avez une
proximité qui est quasiment immédiate
entre leur représentant et vous même et
vous avez une capacité à soi vous
exprimer directement en tant que vous
mêmes citoyens soient a poussé
effectivement votre représentant à
défendre les intérêts de la collectivité
alors ça c'est le schéma idéal et
justement il sauve qui est un pays où ce
schéma idéal fonctionne c'est un pays
qui mesurent 41 mille kilomètres carrés
les neuf dixièmes du territoire est
inhabitable sont inhabitables
c'est-à-dire recouverte soit par de l'au
delà des forêts des montagnes
c'est un pays de 8 millions d'habitants
où millions d'habitants c'est plus
populeux que le danemark la finlande que
la norvège chez les plats population
d'israël
ça n'est pas israël ni lé danemark ni la
finlande ni en norvège c'est un pays où
il y à 24 % d'étrangers résidant dans le
pays je rappelle qu'en france c'est 7%
c'est 7% en italie c'est 7 % en
grande-bretagne c'est
9 % en allemagne là je parle de 24%
c'est un pays multiconfessionnel
c'est un pays où il y a quatre langues
officielles je résume
je mets tout ça dans un shaker d'accord
un gîte
je jette ça sur la table généralement
sur la planète entière ça débouche en
guerre civile
d'accord leur guerre civile c'est à dire
que pendant pendant une période la
minorité opprimée va être massacrés puis
ensuite elle parviendra grâce à des
appuis extérieurs à se retourner contre
les massacreurs et ils deviennent eux
mêmes à leur tour mises d'accord et
c'est donc on connaît le système là ça
n'est pas le cas ça n'est pas le cas ça
n'est pas véritablement un pays en
guerre civile puisque c'est le pays où
il ya le plus grand nombre de prix nobel
par habitant c'est le pays qui dispose
des meilleures universités sur le
continent européen bien avant la france
l'angleterre l'italie l'espagne etc
c'est le pays qui est leader mondial
dans le domaine de l'innovation c'est le
pays qui a quasiment résolu la question
du chômage puisqu'il ya le plein emploi
pour les adultes aux alentours de 3 2%
et pour les 15 24 ans qui doivent être
nombreux dans cette salle c'est
également quasiment le plein emploi avec
un taux de chômage de l'ordre de 5 je
rappelle que quand même dans l'ensemble
de l'europe aujourd'hui il est de 24%
avec des pointes qui sont pourtant
absolument sidérantes himalayenne dans
certaines régions malheureuse d'europe
alors ce pays écouter ça n'est pas le
pakistan ce pays
ça n'est pas le honduras ce pays c'est
celui là
d'accord il est voisin il y à 571 km de
frontière commune avec la france et on
peut s'interroger comment cela se
fait-il que un tel pays fonctionne
finalement aussi bien écouter
il fonctionne aussi bien d'abord ce pays
ses 26 cantons ses 26 états souverains
un lac ont fait de la fédération
helvétique la confédération helvétique
ce sont 26 et a26 état souverain 26
cantons chaque canton à sa constitution
chaque canton à son executive son
parlement
ces tribunaux
on peut vraiment se demander comment est
ce que une telle mosaïque réussi à
rester stable réussit à rester organisé
et structuré
mais à écouter c'est très très simple
les suisses les citoyens suisses ont mis
sur pied deux droits politiques qui sont
fondamentaux et qui leur permettent
d'avoir barre sur leurs élus et de
rédiger eux-mêmes les lois ces deux
instruments fondamentaux sont le droit
de référendum c'est à dire la capacité
que tout citoyen à de s'opposer à une
loi qu'il considère comme étant tu me
néfaste pour ses intérêts ou néfaste
pour la collectivité droit de référendum
et il y à une autre un autre droit
politique fondamentale qui est
l'initiative populaire qui permet aux
citoyens suisses de proposer une loi la
soumettre à l'ensemble de la population
l'ensemble de la population et des
cantons se prononcent sur le projet de
loi
elle est acceptée où elle est refusée
bref tous les trois mois tous les trois
mois
les suisses fabriquent leur propre
constitution
il n'ya pas de conseil constitutionnel
en suisse c'est le peuple qui est le
conseil de constitue le col le conseil
constitutionnel je sais pas si vous
mesurez l'importance de cet attribut que
le peuple a conservé c'est à dire que
tous les trois mois
au niveau fédéral et au niveau cantonal
les suisses modifie changent leur
constitution y ajoute de nouveaux textes
etc
vous êtes en train de vous dire oui mais
alors attendez c'est une instabilité
chronique pas du tout il ya une double
stabilité il ya une stabilité sociale et
politique la stabilité sociale elle
remonte à 1937 avec la fameuse paix du
travail
les suisses pour leur bonheur échappe
aux grèves chronique corporatiste qui
paralysent des pans entiers de
l'économie au bénéfice de quelques
petits groupes ce force fortement
structurée et parfaitement nocifs et
depuis 1937 l'ensemble des des
partenaires sociaux se réunissent et
travaille à au bien être collectif
ian stabilité politique qui date depuis
1959 puisque à traves avec le
gouvernement
corps danse tout l'arc politique suisse
se retrouve au sein de l'exécutif suis
c'est à dire des sept ministres les sept
ministres qu'on représente
lanthier arc politique suisse donc je
regarde ce petit pays
je regarde sa stabilité politique je
regarde la richesse qu'elle a qu'il
arrive à produire je regarde son
innovation je regarde à quel point il
est pragmatique à quel point peu lui
chaut de savoir si le chat et rouge vert
ou jaune
la seule chose qui importe c'est que le
chat attrape la souris il n'est pas
question de s'intéresser de savoir si
l'économie administrée aux plus que
l'économie l'économie sociale etc
non la seule chose qui compte c'est
effectivement une efficacité un souci
pragmatique et quand je vois tout ça
quand je vois le fait que le chômage des
jeunes a visiblement été résolus que la
balance commerciale est excédentaire
depuis 16 ans qu'ils arrivent à produire
des dé produire la pharmacie dans la
mécanique de précision dans la chimie à
très haute valeur ajoutée je me dis je
me dis je me dis mais pourquoi donc ne
nous intéresserons pas davantage ne
s'intéresseront pas davantage à un petit
état à une petite structure politique
qui est finalement à quelques kilomètres
d'ici
équipés dont on pourrait tirer un tel
avantage
nous en tant que citoyen je vous
remercie